I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello. Hi there, everybody.
我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士们。大家好。嗨，大家好。
All right, today we're going to talk about counseling, which is Season 7, Episode 2. But first, Angie, I feel like I want to share with our podcast listeners the morning that we had getting here. Okay. We had quite the text thread going this morning with Sam and Cassie, you and me. I've got a summer cold. Yeah. I can't believe I am congested again.
好了，今天我们要谈谈心理咨询，也就是第七季第二集。但首先，安吉，我觉得我想跟我们的播客听众分享一下我们今天早上来这里的经历。好的。今天早上我们、山姆、凯西、你和我，在群里聊得热火朝天。我得了夏季感冒。是的。真不敢相信我又鼻塞了。
Like I can't believe it. You just kicked it. I barely kicked it. And now it's back. This is, you know, kids going to camps and I don't know, we're bringing all the stuff home. Jeremy McDerms. So this morning, y'all were checking in with me.
就像我真不敢相信一样。你才刚刚好转。我几乎没好彻底。现在它又回来了。你知道的，孩子们去夏令营，我不知道，我们把所有东西都带回家了。杰里米·麦克德姆斯。所以今天早上，你们都在关心我。
You're like, Jenna, are you okay to record? And I was like, I'm going to rally. I'm going to do it. And then Sam was like, yeah, I was like, I don't bring enough to this podcast. I'm going to bring food poisoning. Oh, Sam. And you know, Cassie and I are looking pretty good this morning. Yeah, I don't appreciate that.
你们就像是，珍娜，你状态还好能录音吗？然后我说，我会振作起来的。我能行。然后山姆说，是的，我说，我对这个播客的贡献不够。我要把食物中毒也带上。哦，山姆。你知道的，凯西和我今天早上看起来气色相当不错。是的，我可不感激这个。
We both just finished off the doughnut. Oh yeah, they have doughnuts in the lobby today. I want to point out, Jenna is almost horizontal. She's almost reclined. She's pulled another chair next to her chair so she can recline. But listen to this. So after Sam and I are both like, we're going to do it, we're going to rally. We got it.
我们俩刚刚吃完甜甜圈。哦，是的，他们今天在大厅里准备了甜甜圈。我想指出的是，珍娜几乎是水平躺着的。她几乎是躺着靠在椅子上的。她在自己的椅子旁边又拉了一把椅子，这样她就可以躺下了。但听着，所以在山姆和我都表示我们要拼一把，我们要振作起来，我们没问题之后。
I reached into my closet to grab my office ladies hoodie and I sliced my finger open on a broken edge of my plastic hanger. Oh. So then I'm like, you know what? It's still okay. Yeah. I'm still going in. Yeah.
我把手伸进衣柜去拿我们的《办公室女士》连帽衫时，我的手指被塑料衣架破损的边缘割破了。哦。然后我就想，你知道吗？没关系。是的。我还是要进去。是的。
So I'm driving in to work and driving my daughter to camp first. And there was this big sort of that moment where someone cut in front of the line of cars that were headed toward this one exit, everything slowed down and I had to slam on the brakes, but I could tell around me that like there was not enough space for everybody. Oh no. Did you get hit? Yeah. Did you hear the noise?
所以我开车去上班，先送我女儿去夏令营。有那么一会儿，有人插队挤到了开往这个出口的车队前面，所有东西都慢了下来，我不得不猛踩刹车，但我能感觉到我周围的空间不够每个人用。噢，不。你被撞了吗？是的。你听到声音了吗？
Did you got hit? Did the brake noise before it? Like where you know what's going? No, it wasn't that. I just could feel like the time and space around me and I said out loud to my daughter. I said, I think we're going to be in an accident and then the person behind us ran into us. It was a fender bender to call it an accident. It's not really an accident.
你被撞了吗？之前有刹车声吗？就像你知道会发生什么的那种？不，不是那样的。我只是能感觉到周围的时间和空间，我对女儿大声说。我说，我想我们要出车祸了，然后后面的那个人就撞上了我们。这只是一起轻微的剐蹭，如果把它叫做车祸的话。其实不算是什么车祸。
And then of course it's LA, so I'm expecting this person is going to take off. But I'm like, no way he's pulling over. Yeah. He pulled over. Oh. He gets out of his car. Young guy. Uh-huh.
然后当然这里是洛杉矶，所以我预料这个人会逃逸。但我想，没门，他把车停下了。是的。他把车靠边停了。哦。他从车里出来了。一个小伙子。嗯哼。
So sweet. He's wearing a vote for Pedro t-shirt. Oh, Napoleon Dynamite fan. Yes. Yes. He's a big bumper. Nothing to write home about. We're all going to be fine.
人太好了。他穿着一件“为佩德罗投票”的T恤。哦，《拿破仑 dynamite》的粉丝。是的。是的。他是个大号保龄球手。没什么值得大惊小怪的。我们都会没事的。
But here's the kicker. Guess where he was going to go to work? Where? The Wizarding World of Harry Potter. Oh, at Universal. Yes, which we had just been to a few days ago. And I got so excited. I was like, oh my gosh.
但妙处就在这里。猜猜他要去哪里上班？哪里？哈利·波特的魔法世界。哦，在环球影城。是的，我们几天前刚去过。我当时激动坏了。我简直，哦天哪。
He had just moved here from Hawaii. He had borrowed this car from the person he's living with to drive to his job at Wizarding World of Harry Potter. You know, they all talk in accents in the Wizarding World of Harry Potter. It's very theatrical, the whole experience. And I said to him, do they make you speak in accents? And he said, no. If you have an accent, you can speak in it.
他刚从夏威夷搬来这里。他向合租的人借了这辆车，开车去他在哈利·波特魔法世界的岗位上班。你知道，在哈利·波特魔法世界里，他们说话都带着口音。整个体验非常戏剧化。我对他说，他们强迫你们带着口音说话吗？他说，没有。如果你有口音，你就可以用它说话。
But he said he does it anyway because he's an aspiring actor and he likes to do voice work. We had a lovely chat on the side of the road, and now here I am. And he's in the lobby, and he's going to, no kidding. I love the idea that he bumped into Pam from the office and you were excited about his job. I was. I was like, tell me everything.
但他说是他自己坚持要这么做的，因为他是一个有抱负的演员，喜欢做配音工作。我们在路边进行了一次愉快的交谈，然后我就来到这里了。而他就在大厅里，他打算去，说实话。我喜欢这种想法，他撞上了《办公室》里的帕姆，而且你对他的工作很感兴趣。我是。我当时想，快把一切都告诉我。
No, he did end up recognizing me and I took a photo with him. So if you know this guy and he tags us, I'll try to find it. I'll repost it. I love that you were just chatting him up on the side of the road because I would have been there for all of that. And then I would have been like, where do you do it today? I know. I was like, well, I should probably go.
不，他最后确实认出了我，我和他合了影。所以如果你认识这个人，而且他艾特了我们，我会试着找到它。我会重新发出来的。我喜欢你当时在路边和他闲聊的样子，因为我肯定会把所有这些都经历一遍。然后我就会想，你今天在哪里工作？我懂的。我当时想，嗯，我大概得走了。
I have to go to work. I have to drop my daughter off at camp. Exactly. But we're all fine and we're here. I think I'm maybe good for the day. You're good. You're good. I don't know.
我得去上班。我得送女儿去夏令营。没错。但我们都很好，而且我们在这里。我觉得我今天状态可能还不错。你很好。你很好。我不知道。
Knock on wood. Knock on wood. All right. That was my morning tangent. Should we get started? Let's do it. The counseling was written by BJ Novak and directed by Jeffrey Blitz. And here's your summary.
敲木头。敲木头。好吧。那是我早上的题外话。我们开始吧？开始吧。《心理咨询》由BJ·诺瓦克编剧，杰弗里·布里茨执导。这是你的剧情梗概。
As a punishment for spanking Luke in front of the entire office, Michael must complete six hour-long counseling sessions with Toby. Dwight seeks a pretty woman-style revenge on a salesman who snubbed him at the Steamtown Mall and Pam scams her way into a new job title. I mean, in this episode, I was like, Pam, who are you? You know, when this happened, it was sort of like one of those controversial character moments. We got a lot of messages about it.
作为在整个办公室人员面前打卢克屁股的惩罚，迈克尔必须与托比完成六次为期一小时的心理咨询。德怀特对一个在史蒂姆敦购物中心冷落他的推销员进行了一场《漂亮女人》式的报复，而帕姆则通过欺骗手段谋得了一个新职位。我的意思是，在这一集里，我想，帕姆，你是谁？你知道，当这件事发生时，这有点像那种引发争议的角色时刻。我们收到了很多关于它的消息。
And we also got mail. So I'll read it later. Okay. All right. Fast fact number one, I mentioned that Michael has to do these counseling sessions with Toby. Yeah. That's our A storyline.
我们还收到了信件。所以我待会儿读。好的。好了，第一条幕后速写，我提到迈克尔必须与托比进行这些心理咨询。是的。那是我们的A故事线。
It's revealed at two minutes and 52 seconds that Toby has a degree in social work from a Temple University. I took a picture of it. He's standing so proudly by it, and then it goes wonky. Yes. Well, the shot is only two seconds long, but a lot went into getting that diploma because it is a real diploma from the actual university. We got a letter from Raymond Betzner in Williamsburg, Virginia that says this, I was the associate
剧情在两分五十二秒时揭示，托比拥有天普大学的社会工作学位。我拍了张照片。他站在它旁边显得非常自豪，然后画面就扭曲了。是的。好吧，这个镜头只有两秒长，但是为了弄到那张文凭，我们付出了很多努力，因为它是来自那所实际大学的真实文凭。我们收到了来自弗吉尼亚州威廉斯堡的雷蒙德·贝茨纳的一封信，信上说，我是副总裁
vice president for marketing and communications at Temple University in 2010 and helped get Toby his degree. The degree is real. How can Toby be a graduate from Temple University? Oh, well, lady, we got a bunch of mail about like, when was this happening? Was this before or after he was in the seminary? Was it before or after he worked in advertising? Toby's backstory is much like Andy's.
2010年，我担任天普大学市场营销与传播副总裁，并帮助托比拿到了学位。这个学位是真的。托比怎么会是天普大学的毕业生？哦，好吧，女士，我们收到了很多关于这事的信件：这究竟是什么时候发生的？这在他进神学院之前还是之后？这在他从事广告工作之前还是之后？托比的背景故事就像安迪的一样。
It's just a free fall. It is. Raymond went on to say, I got an email one day from a member of the office staff. I'm retired now and no longer have access to my email, so I can't tell you who exactly it was. I was told they wanted Toby to have a master's in social work from Temple University and could I make it happen? And naturally, they needed it fast.
简直就是自由落体。确实如此。雷蒙德接着说，我有一天收到了一封来自办公室员工的电子邮件。我现在退休了，不再能访问我的邮箱，所以我不能告诉你具体是谁。我被告知他们希望托比拥有天普大学的社会工作硕士学位，我能办到吗？理所当然地，他们需要得很快。
Raymond goes on to say, if you know anything about higher education, you need to know two things. First, we take degrees and diplomas very seriously. And second, higher education doesn't move quickly. But I was a fan of the show. I thought it was worth a shot. It took calls to the university registrar, the university council, and the conjoaling of several others to clear the path for this to happen.
雷蒙德接着说，如果你对高等教育有所了解，你需要知道两件事。首先，我们非常重视学位和文凭。其次，高等教育的行动并不迅速。但我一直是这个节目的粉丝。我觉得值得一试。这需要给大学注册处打电话，找大学法律顾问，还要说服其他好几个人，才能为这件事扫清道路。
Along the way, I kept getting nervous calls from folks at the office because they needed it soon. I was trying. Oh my gosh. Then Raymond says, I will also admit that I tried to get a little something in return for all this effort. Oh, Raymond. I wanted to know if Michael and Holly got together before Steve Carell leaves the show.
一路上，我不断接到来自办公室工作人员的紧张电话，因为他们很快就要用到。我很努力了。哦天哪。然后雷蒙德说，我也承认，我曾试图为这一切努力换取一点回报。哦，雷蒙德。我想知道迈克尔和霍莉在史蒂夫·卡瑞尔离开剧组之前是否走到了一起。
Raymond. Did they tell him? No. He says the staff at the office aren't dumb and they didn't let anything out in advance. I love that what he wanted was scoop on storylines. Exactly. Not a set visit. Right.
雷蒙德。他们告诉他了吗？没有。他说办公室的工作人员并不傻，他们没有提前透露任何消息。我喜欢他想要的是剧情爆料。没错。不是参观片场。对。
Not like an autographed something. Tell me about Holly and Michael. He needed to know. He said, I'm pleased to say we were able to get the diploma approved and printed and set to California. The photo of Toby pointing to his Temple University School of Social Work diploma was hot on Temple University's social media for weeks. So I reached out to Randy Cordray about this, Angela, and he said that the writers had originally
不是像亲笔签名那样的东西。告诉我关于霍莉和迈克尔的事。他必须知道。他说，我很高兴地说，我们成功让文凭获批并打印出来，寄到了加利福尼亚州。托比指着他的天普大学社会工作学院文凭的照片在天普大学的社交媒体上火了几个星期。所以我为此联系了兰迪·科德雷，安吉拉，他说编剧们最初
considered Wake Forest University for Toby, but when they inquired about getting a degree in social work, they found out that Wake Forest does not offer a degree in social work. Just sociology. So that's when the writers pivoted to Temple and James Carey solved the mystery for Raymond. It was Phil Shea who reached out to him. Phil Shea sent him a prepaid FedEx envelope to send back two diplomas and in return, he did send Raymond two Dunder Mifflin hats. Aw.
曾考虑过让托比去维克森林大学，但当他们打听社会工作学位时，发现维克森林大学不提供社会工作专业，只有社会学。所以编剧们当时转向了天普大学，詹姆斯·凯瑞为雷蒙德解开了谜团。是菲尔·希尔联系了他。菲尔·希尔给他寄了一个预付的联邦快递信封，让他把两份毕业证寄回去，作为回报，他确实寄给雷蒙德两顶邓德米夫林的帽子。啊。
So Raymond, do you still have your Dunder Mifflin hat? Tell us a photo of you with your hat. Please, Raymond. Can we put you in Office Lady's stories? We would love it. Well, I love knowing all of that. I mean, those little details always blow my mind. Same.
所以雷蒙德，你还留着你的邓德米夫林帽子吗？给我们发一张你戴着帽子的照片吧。求你了，雷蒙德。我们能把你发到“办公室女士”的动态里吗？我们非常乐意。嗯，我很高兴知道所有这些。我是说，那些小细节总是让我大开眼界。我也是。
All right. Are you ready for fast fact number two? Yes. All right. This one is a little detail from Pam's storyline of trying to get her new job. We got a lot of mail from folks in Australia. Oh, yeah. Because she talks about Canberra.
好了。准备好听第二个快速冷知识了吗？准备好了。好的。这个是关于帕姆为了找新工作而展开的剧情中的一个小细节。我们收到了许多来自澳大利亚朋友的邮件。哦，是的。因为她提到了堪培拉。
Yes. We got mail from Kimmy G in Canberra, Australia, who said, I grew up in the barra. And this is just so random because Canberra is a tiny, freezing, often missed city in Australia. Most people don't even realize that it is the Australian capital. And then she gave this fun fact. Let's hear the fun fact. The fun fact is, when they were deciding where they should put the capital of Australia,
是的。我们收到了来自澳大利亚堪培拉的吉米的邮件，她说，我在堪培拉长大的。这太随机了，因为堪培拉是澳大利亚一个很小、很冷、经常被忽略的城市。大多数人甚至不知道它是澳大利亚的首都。然后她分享了一个有趣的冷知识。让我们听听这个冷知识。这个冷知识是，当他们决定把澳大利亚首都要设在哪里时，
they couldn't decide between Sydney or Melbourne, and it was a really heated debate. And they couldn't agree. So they literally built a whole new city in the middle of both of those cities. Just to make it the capital? Yes. Isn't that amazing? Yeah. Well, Kimmy G got me curious about Canberra, and I started looking up details about the
他们在悉尼和墨尔本之间举棋不定，这是一场非常激烈的争论。他们无法达成一致。于是他们干脆在那两座城市的正中间新建了一座城市。仅仅为了让它成为首都？是的。这不是很神奇吗？是的。嗯，吉米勾起了我对堪培拉的好奇，我开始查找关于这个
city. It looks very cool. But the thing that really stood out to me is that there are all of these rumors, I guess, for stories, Scuttlebutt, lore, lore, Canberra lore, maybe urban legends, that there are these secret underground tunnels throughout the whole city. And I guess the rumors are that these tunnels have been used for, like, international espionage. Oh, super sleuthing? Yes, sleuthing in Canberra.
城市的信息。它看起来非常酷。但真正吸引我的是，有各种各样的传言，我想是各种故事、八卦、传说、堪培拉传说，也许是都市传说，说整个城市地下都有这些秘密地下通道。我想传言说这些通道曾被用于国际间谍活动之类的。哦，超级侦探活动？是的，在堪培拉搞侦探活动。
So I digged some more, and I think most of the rumors have been debunked. Mm. But then I started to think that the debunking was part of a conspiracy to hide the tunnels. Like, I went so deep on the tunnels, here's what I've decided. Okay. Lady, when Mom Detectives is in its, like, fifth season, we need, yes, we need like an international episode, we investigate the tunnels of Canberra. Oh my gosh.
所以我又做了一些深入了解，我觉得大部分传言已经被辟谣了。嗯。但后来我开始觉得，辟谣其实是掩盖这些地下通道的阴谋的一部分。天哪，我在地下通道这件事上陷得太深了，这就是我得出的结论。好吧。女士们，当“妈妈侦探”拍到第五季的时候，我们需要，是的，我们需要一集国际篇，去调查堪培拉的地下通道。天哪。
Yes. Lady, I knew that Canberra was the nation's capital because one of my best friends ever, Micah, is from Canberra. Oh my gosh. Yes. I didn't know that. Does he know about the tunnels? I don't know.
是的。女士，我知道堪培拉是国家首都，因为我最好的朋友之一米卡就是堪培拉人。天哪。是的。我不知道这个。他知道那些地下通道的事吗？我不知道。
We can call him. Should we call him? Yes. Yes, we can get to the bottom of it right now. We're going to call my friend Michael Peters, also known as Micah. Let's see, let's give him a buzz. Hi. Hi, Micah, we're calling you from the podcast, it's Angela and Jenna.
我们可以打电话给他。我们应该给他打电话吗？是的。是的，我们现在就可以一探究竟。我们要给我的朋友迈克尔·彼得斯打电话，也就是米卡。让我们看看，给他打个电话。嗨。嗨，米卡，我们在播客里给你打电话，我是安吉拉和珍娜。
Hi. Hi, how are you? We have a random question for you about Canberra, your hometown. Yes. Okay. Here is what I need to know. Is it true that there's an elaborate tunnel system underneath the city that is used for espionage?
嗨。嗨，你好吗？我们有个关于你的家乡堪培拉的随机问题要问你。好的。这就是我想知道的。城底下真的有一个复杂的地下通道系统，被用来进行间谍活动吗？
Oh my gosh. Have you heard this rumor? Yes, that I do not know. I heard that there were tunnels underneath the Parliament House, because the whole government sits in Canberra. Yes. I don't know about secret spy tunnels. So I was able to confirm that there are little tunnels under the Parliament House, but I read
哦，天哪。你听说过这个传言吗？是的，这个我不知道。我听说议会大厦下面有通道，因为整个政府都在堪培拉办公。是的。我不知道什么秘密间谍通道。所以我能够证实议会大厦下面确实有一些小通道，但我读到
this rumor that their secret passageways go all the way under Lake Burley Griffin. Wow, that's very cool. I did not know that though. You want to tell them what you told me last night, what Canberra's known for? Two things you said. Well, Canberra is the capital of Australia. It's like Australia's DC. And it's also famous because it's where they make all the porn in Australia.
过这样一个传言，说它们的秘密通道一直延伸到伯利格里芬湖下方。哇，这太酷了。不过我倒不知道这个。你想告诉她们你昨晚跟我说的堪培拉以什么闻名吗？你说的两件事。嗯，堪培拉是澳大利亚的首都。它就像澳大利亚的华盛顿特区。它还很有名，因为那是澳大利亚所有色情片拍摄的地方。
It's the Van Nuys of Australia, and I'm pretty sure we're also the only state. Because it's a territory like DC, the Australian Capital Territory, where you're allowed to have fireworks. Oh, how about that? Fireworks and porn, and tunnels. And like legal prostitution too. Oh, well, Canberra, stepping it up. What about gambling?
它是澳大利亚的凡努斯，而且我很确定我们也是唯一一个拥有。因为它像华盛顿特区一样是个领地，澳大利亚首都领地，在那里你是被允许燃放烟花的。哦，是吗？烟花、色情片和地下通道。还有合法的卖淫活动。哦，好吧，堪培拉，真有一套。赌博呢？
Can I gamble there? Yeah, there's a casino, yep. Wow. But I think you can do that in other states too. It's not like in the US. I see, I see. All right, Mika, thank you so much for being our 411 call about Canberra. Yes, our Canberra expert.
我可以在那里赌博吗？对，那里有赌场，是的。哇。但我认为你在其他州也可以这么做。它不像美国那样。我明白了，我明白了。好了，米卡，非常感谢你成为我们关于堪培拉的热线咨询对象。是的，我们的堪培拉专家。
All right, love you. Okay, love you guys. Bye. Bye. Well, we learned a lot of things we didn't think we were going to learn about Canberra. Yes, we still are unsure about the tunnels, but I'll tell you what, this episode of Mom Detectives just got more fun. Just got real interesting.
好了，爱你们。好的，爱你们哦。拜拜。拜拜。好吧，我们学到了很多原以为不会了解到的关于堪培拉的知识。是的，我们对地下通道仍然不太确定，但我告诉你，这一集的“妈妈侦探”变得更有趣了。变得真的很有意思了。
I mean, there's a lot that the Mom Detectives are going to see when we go there. It's going to stumble across. Wowzer. All right, thank you, Mika. Yeah. Let's move to FastFact number three. It's just a little location breakdown. Our final storyline of this episode is going to have Dwight going to the Steamtown Mall.
我是说，等我们去那里的时候，“妈妈侦探”会看到很多东西。会无意中发现很多。哇塞。好的，谢谢你，米卡。是的。让我们转到第三个快速冷知识。这只是一个简单的取景地解析。我们这集的最后一个故事情节是德怀特要去蒸汽镇购物中心。
We went to the Burbank Town Center Mall to shoot this. And that precious heirloom store that was created from scratch by our set decorating crew headed by Steve Rothstein, they used an empty store space on the second floor. And Randy shared with me that the original outline for this episode, like it never even made it into a script, originally had some scenes in a food court. And so, you know, they start prepping the episode long before we shoot it. So our locations manager, Kyle Alexander, actually had to find an empty store that we could dress that was also next to a food court.
我们去了伯班克市中心购物中心拍摄这个。那个珍贵的传家宝店是由史蒂夫·罗斯坦领导的布景装饰团队从零开始打造的，他们利用了二楼一个空置的店铺空间。兰迪跟我分享说，这集最初的大纲，甚至都没能写进剧本里，原本在美食广场有一些场景。所以，你知道的，他们在我们拍摄很久之前就开始筹备这一集了。所以我们的外景经理凯尔·克斯坦实际上不得不找一个我们可以布置的空店铺，它还得挨着一个美食广场。
And he did it. We never used the food court, but pretty amazing. I mean, just another example of how they have to, like, always be ready. And then maybe we didn't even need it. They always hustled. But, ladies, that's all I got. Those are my FastFacts. Well, before we get into this episode, I have a little something.
他做到了。我们从未用过那个美食广场，但真的很神奇。我是说，这只是又一个例子，说明他们必须总是处于随时准备好的状态。然后也许我们根本用不上它。他们总是雷厉风行。但是，女士们，我只有这么多了。这就是我的快速冷知识。好吧，在我们进入这一集之前，我有一点小东西要分享。
Yes. I wanted to share something from one of our office ladies listeners. A lot of you might have heard of Elise Meyers, and if you don't, go find her on Instagram or on the Tickety Talk, as I call it. I'm following Elise on Instagram, and I love her. She is a delight and brings absolute joy to the world. Yeah. And she's hilarious.
是的。我想分享一位我们的“办公室女士”听众发来的内容。你们很多人可能听说过伊莉丝·迈尔斯，如果没有，去Instagram或者我称之为“抖音”的平台上找她。我在Instagram上关注了伊莉丝，我很喜欢她。她是一个开心果，给世界带来了绝对的欢乐。是的。而且她非常搞笑。
I mean, two words, Taco Bell, if you know, you know. That one went viral. But you guys, she's also a fantastic singer. And when I jokingly said on the podcast, can someone write a Whispers in the Break Room song when we were talking about cover up? She did it. It's awesome, and you got to hear it. I overheard that Kelly's Birkenbag is actually fake, and that Michael can't remember his
我是说，两个词，塔可钟，懂的都懂。那个视频在网上疯传。但是伙计们，她也是个出色的歌手。当我开玩笑地在播客里问，当我们在谈论掩盖真相时，有没有人能写一首《休息室里的低语》这首歌？她真的写了。太棒了，你们一定要听听。我无意中听到凯莉的爱马仕柏金包其实是假的，迈克尔记不清自己的
own middle name, and that Andy is always two hours late. These are the Whispers in the Break Room. I heard that Meredith turned her desk into a mini bar, and that Stanley schedules meetings and just sits in his car, and that Ryan didn't graduate with a master's degree. Elise, that's what I heard, but you didn't hear it from me. These are the Whispers in the Break Room. If you want to know what's going on, and you want it to come to you, the Whispers in the Break Room, just stick around long enough and learn a thing or two.
中间名，安迪总是迟到两个小时。这些都是休息室里的低语。我听说梅雷迪思把她的办公桌变成了一个迷你酒吧，斯坦利安排了会议却只坐在自己的车里，瑞恩没有获得硕士学位。伊莉丝，这就是我听说的，但你不是从我这里听来的。这些都是休息室里的低语。如果你想知道发生了什么，又想让消息主动找上你，休息室里的低语，只要在这里待够久，就能学到一两招。
And that was Whispers in the Break Room. Back to you, Angela and Jenna. Is that amazing? Amazing. I love it so much. When I saw that, you know, I follow her on Instagram, and when I saw that, I was like, oh my God, and you texted me. It was like a simultaneous thing where we're like, oh my gosh, we're seeing this.
这就是《休息室里的低语》。交给你了，安吉拉和珍娜。是不是很棒？太棒了。我太喜欢了。当我看到那个时，你知道的，我在Instagram上关注了她，当我看到那个时，我心想，天哪，然后你就给我发了短信。那就像是一个同步发生的时刻，我们俩都觉得，哦天哪，我们正在看这个。
Elise, I love so much about that song. It also kind of reminded me of when Dolly Parton would harmonize with Emilew Harris and Linda Ronstadt, but you're doing it all with yourself. It's like my brain doesn't even understand how you do it, and it's amazing. Thank you for letting us play that on Office Ladies Elise. All right. On that delightful note, let's take a break, because when we come back, Jim and Pam are late to work.
伊莉丝，我太喜欢这首歌的许多地方了。它也某种程度上让我想起了当年多莉·帕顿与埃米露·哈里斯和琳达·朗斯塔特进行和声时的情景，但你全程都是在和自己和声。就像我的大脑甚至无法理解你是怎么做到的，这太神奇了。谢谢你让我们在“办公室女士”里播放这首歌，伊莉丝。好了。带着这美妙的心情，我们休息一下，因为当我们回来时，吉姆和帕姆上班迟到了。
Well, we are back, and Dwight is, he's shaming Jim and Pam because they're late. Again. But you know what? You know, because Jim had to open that bathroom door a while back, they didn't get into the daycare that's close to Dunder Mifflin, and now they have to drive all the way across town. Dwight sees an opportunity. He's like, hey, guess what?
好吧，我们回来了，德怀特正在羞辱吉姆和帕姆，因为他们迟到了。又迟到了。但你知道吗？你知道的，因为吉姆前不久不得不去推那扇卫生间门，他们没能进那家离邓德米夫林很近的日托中心，现在他们不得不开车穿过整个城镇。德怀特看到了机会。他就像是，嘿，你猜怎么着？
There is a daycare center right here in this very building. Dwight is going to give Jim and Pam a whole tour. Yes. The Sesame Avenue Daycare for infants and toddlers, where Moe has apparently been painting in the dark with a cabbage patch doll strapped to his chest, is located in the former Michael Scott Paper Company. Well, Jenna, I thought I would break down the special features of the Sesame Avenue Daycare Center for infants and toddlers.
就在这栋大楼里，正好有一家日托中心。德怀特要给吉姆和帕姆进行一次全面的参观。是的。芝麻大道婴幼儿日托中心，莫显然一直在那里绑着一个卷心菜娃娃在胸前在黑暗中画画，它就位于前迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司的旧址。好吧，珍娜，我想我来剖析一下芝麻大道婴幼儿日托中心的特色。
According to Dwight, this is what your child's experience will include. A language skills and cognitive development area, which is just an eye chart on the old rusty shower. There is one blue bouncy ball on an otherwise empty wire shelf, a magical toy box that has plastic forks and knives, and one soy sauce packet. He was very embarrassed by that. I know, he should be. He's apologized.
He should be. There are four metal buckets. One is a restroom, one is a feeding trough, one is a play bucket, and one is for a possible plant. And for those of you who love a good background catch, if you go to 45 seconds, the cabbage patch doll strapped to Moe's chest only has one red shoe on and the other foot just has a sock. Did you have cabbage patch kids when you were younger?
Oh, I was overseas and I came stateside and everyone had one and I was like, I need this in my life. So, yeah, I got one. What'd you name it? I don't remember. You don't remember? This was such a big deal. I had two cabbage patch kids and I remember their names so clearly.
Christine Marie and Kasey Alexander. Kasey Alexander had curly arbor hair and Christine Marie had blonde ponytails. Mine had blonde hair with some freckles. I don't remember her name. You didn't love her. I didn't love her. Clearly. I got her late in the game and she clearly didn't make a stamp on me.
Oh, wow. You remember I was trying to get Mandy Moore to name her son Kasey Alexander in honor of my cabbage patch kid. I don't know why she didn't listen to you. Well, she has the second baby coming. Maybe she'll take my advice this time. Mandy, Kasey Alexander, it's waiting for you. Although let's point out none of your children are named Kasey Alexander.
Well, listen, I had to ask Randy a question when I saw this cold open, Angela. I needed to know did they have to clean out this room again? Because it was storage. Yeah. He said no. This is what he said. He wrote, we had finally gotten smarter and left the room empty and found a different place for post-production storage.
He was just so fed up. He was like, fine. Randy also shared with me that Mike Scherr, who plays Moe's, was insanely busy over at Parks and Rec and that the writers of the office would often try to put Moe's in an episode and then Randy would go check with Mike's schedule and then he wouldn't be able to do it and they would have to take Moe's out. This happened many times. So Randy said, finally, finally, Mike was like, yeah, my schedule's totally clear that
day. I can come. I drop a cabbage patch to my chest. And everyone was so excited because we got to have Moe's back. Well this episode opens with Toby and Michael sitting opposite one another in the break room. They're having a full on stare down. Michael looks like the emperor in Star Wars when he's given that death look. No, I didn't know that because I haven't seen those films.
I know you think of Emperor Palpatine. Yes. Yes, thank you. Well, that's Michael in this opening scene. Thank you, Sam. I believe you. We had a fan catch from Zach Kay from Acton, Ontario, Canada who said, not really a question but a comment.
I love how this episode begins with 15 seconds, yes, I counted it of silence before any dialogue. This must be a record for the longest silence in the show. What's the longest silence? 27 seconds of silence. Oh, with Jim and Pam. On the booze cruise. My God, I was in it. I was in the longest.
I'm like, what are you talking about? I wrote about it in a book. Welcome to my summer cold, everyone. But yes, I have to say, I thought it was a pretty badass move that the episode opens with so much silence. Well, I love how seriously Toby has taken this chance to help Michael. He moves a small love seat. He puts a chair in there, a little coffee table.
He has a plant, a box of Kleenex. He's going to get down to business and have therapy in the break room. We had some fan questions about this setup, the first ones from Nicole Q from Bowie, Maryland, who would like to know where did Toby get these sofas from for the setup? They're in the annex in the little hallway. Oh, I was thinking they were from front reception. Because remember in the injury, Michael moves the couch from front reception into the conference room.
I thought they were the ones that were in the annex low lobby area. You're probably right. Closer. Closer. Not as big of a move. Thanks, Ann. You're welcome. Now, we have a fan catch from Emily J and Ohio, who has some comments about the little
plant that you said Toby put on the table. What are the comments? Emily's theory is that the plant looks exactly like the one that died when Pam was on maternity leave and Emily thinks maybe Toby brought it back to life just to impress Pam. Emily. That is amazing. I sort of just thought Toby took Pam's plant. Yeah.
Was it Pam? Can I borrow this for today? Yeah. I wasn't sure because Pam has a different plant on her desk now. You know the one with the bow. It looks almost like bamboo or something. So I don't know where this ivy plant came from. Well, Emily, it definitely looks like a Pam plant.
I agree. White is going to just burst into the bullpen telling everyone they must boycott Steamtown Mall, also the kiosk, cancel all your business with Steamtown Mall. And then Ryan has one of my favorite lines. Ryan says, America is one big mall. I loved that line too. Did you know there's a mall like outside of New York and you can go skiing in it? What?
Yeah, and surfing. How do you ski in a mall? They have an indoor skiing thing. My son found it because he loves skiing and he is trying to find a place to ski in the summer and he would like to ski in a mall in New York. If you go, will you please send me a picture? Of course. Please.
I feel like there's a good chance we're going to end up skiing in this mall at some point in our lives. I'm so curious. Jim wants to know, did something happen? Andy asked Dwight for context, but Dwight tells him you don't want to know. Yeah. Back in the therapy break room, Toby is really trying to connect with Michael, trying to get him to share about himself.
And Michael is just saying a whole bunch of baloney to Toby, trying to get a rise out of him. This would have led to a series of talking heads where the bullpen shares their thoughts on Michael getting therapy. Oh, please. In the episode, it starts with Phyllis. She says, I'm glad Michael is getting help. He has a lot of issues and he's stupid.
This runner would have continued. Here are a few from the shooting draft. These were must shoots. See if you can guess who said which talking head. All right. First one up. Sam, Cassie, Jenna. Here we go.
I'm ready. Michael isn't complex enough to need therapy. Can't someone just calmly explain to him what's wrong with him? Oh, Oscar? Yes. Very nice. All right. Next one.
It is high time. High time. Angela? Is it you? Stanley. Okay. I think that line reading was just so good. Yeah.
Okay. Angela does have one and I thought rather than me reading it, let's just play it the way I said it on the day. Reading about how many feelings you have is a form of bragging. We get it. You have a lot of feelings. Whoop-de-doo. Wow.
She's just so put out with everyone sharing their feelings. And Ryan has one that comes later in the episode. Oh, it's the tag. Yes. Well, we had a fan question from Sarah L in San Antonio, Texas who said, I would love to know if there is a backstory as to why Michael hates Toby so much. I feel like Michael has such a blind affection for his employees that there must be something more to his hatred for Toby that explains it.
Or is it just the classic angle of manager hates HR? I looked into this. And Michael has a line when he's meeting Holly for the first time. And he says that his job is to quote make the office fun while HR's job is to make the office lame. So Toby's the fun stopper. Yes. And we kind of knew that.
But then I found this amazing interview with Paul Lieberstein where he talks about this. How did they come up with in the writer's room this dynamic of Michael hating Toby so much? And he said that Michael's hatred of Toby goes back to a deleted scene from the Alliance. This is where they found this like true hatred of Toby. In the scene, Toby is coming in to sign Meredith's birthday card. And Paul said, I just go in, write something quickly and leave. That's the scene.
But when they were shooting the scene, I guess it took Paul a long time to physically write down what he was going to write down. I have a memory of this that he was writing in the card and it took a bit. Paul said, I could just feel him watching me and I could feel this hatred burning. And he said that Steve told him afterwards that it was in that moment that he decided as Michael to hate Toby. And then Paul said, it's really terrifying to act with Steve because he misses nothing. And that was when they ran with it, that Paul went to the writers and said, Michael hates
Toby. Because you know, if Jim took a long time to write a message, he would have all the patients in the world. Yeah. But Toby not really knowing what to write and taking a bit, Michael's like, ah, yeah. And then of course that led to one of my favorite lines, I hate so much about the way you choose to be, which is what sums it all up. Yeah.
We're about to start a whole new story arc for Pam. She's not having a great sales day. I know. She's just going to own that she sucks at it. She like puts her head on her desk and Jim knows too. Yeah. We had a fan question from Cassandra P and Madison, Wisconsin, who said, this is one of my favorite office episodes.
And if I had an Angela style note card to describe this episode, I would call it full Pam. Oh, I love it. Pam truly becomes the main character in this episode and it sets her up for empowerment and strength for the rest of the series. Also, the season Pam's makeup is 100% on point. Go Pam. Oh, you look super cute.
I know. Pam got really good with eyeliner. She did. I don't know what happened to her over the summer. Like we said, I got married over the summer, so I was just glowing. I think maybe that's part of it. You were just a happy person. What's up next, lady?
Let's see. Oh, what's up next is John Krasinski breaking a lot. He is so tickled by Andy coming up to Dwight. It's saying, did you call my clients and use the F word? Yeah. There it is. Five minutes, 13 seconds. John is looking at Ed and it clearly starts breaking in the background.
Well we find out why Dwight wants to boycott the Steamtown Mall. It's because he went there with Moes and he went to precious heirlooms and they wouldn't let him in. Yeah, he saw this amazing wizard holding a crystal. Yeah, he wanted this nice thing. He's so rarely treats himself to nice things. He made himself vulnerable. Yeah.
He wanted it and they denied him. Yeah. Entry. Kelly says, you need a pretty woman, their asses. Everyone agrees. Well, except Creed, who says they should start their own mall. Yeah, I know. I love that line.
Jim offers to go back to the store with Dwight to teach them a lesson. Andy's like, I'm coming too. This starts a hilarious storyline. Andy's going to start off with a talking head where he says, did you assume that I would automatically side with the rich snobby shop owner? He starts taking off his fancy cufflinks and throwing them, takes off his tie clip. There was a candy bag alt for Andy. Oh, please.
Mm-hmm. Here's what it said. I love revenge. Well, not like violent revenge, not like Kill Bill, more like legally blonde. Nobody's getting the top of their skull sliced off today. Thank you very much. Didn't sign up for that. That's right.
I love that Andy is a legally blonde fan. This leads into my personal favorite talking head. It's Dwight. And Andy. And Jim. And then Kelly. Yes. And all they're trying to do is tell us the famous scene from Pretty Woman where Julia
Roberts gets her revenge on the snooty shop owner. Mm-hmm. Big mistake. Huge. That's right. Well, let's take a break because when we get back, full Pam is happening. Sure is. She gets a real big idea.
We're back. And a man enters the office looking for the office administrator and Pam really perks up. Yes. Yes, Pam is like, that's me. I'm the office administrator. And we are not interested. We don't want your blinds, your window treatments.
At eight minutes, 40 seconds, I'm busted. Who's busted? I'm busted. What are you busted for? I'm playing solitaire. On your computer. Yes, Angela Martin would never. Wow.
That's very out of character. Mm-hmm. You should definitely have a spreadsheet on your computer. I know. Well, I want you to know that we have a guest star in the house. Let's hear it. Vincent Angelo, who plays the salesperson, has been on Desperate Housewives, Grey's Anatomy, Parks and Recreation, and House.
It's my new favorite. I don't know what I like more, discovering someone has been on Monk or House. You just like seeing a guest star in the house. I know. When they've been on House. Become my favorite. I also like tracking if people have played more than one character on Lawn Order. I love the big pause you took before Lawn Order.
I know. That's the summer cold. That is. Summer cold. It has you just one second delayed. It's like you're on a satellite feed. Well, Pam's going to have a talking head now where she says, there's a few ways you can get promoted.
One, you can wait for an opening, a new job, you apply for it. That's the main way. Mm-hmm. This way, where you just apparently lie yourself into a new job, so Pam is going to go into the kitchen. She's going to make herself a cup of tea. Oscar's like, what's up with your new position? Congratulations.
And she's clearly trying to suss out from Oscar. What is a reasonable salary for this position? So she's like, yeah, I'm going to make 40K. Maybe 50. He's like 50. She's like, no, no. It's like 41.5. Yeah, 41.5.
Lady, we got some mail about this storyline, and both of these delighted me. Mm-hmm. I feel so proud. The first one is from Kelly M. in Melbourne, Australia, who said, a couple of years ago, I was inspired by Pam's storyline in this episode where she just starts telling people she's the office administrator. So I did it myself. What?
Yeah. She said, I work in a school, and a couple of years ago, I decided we really needed a sustainability coordinator. OK. But it's quite hard to get new roles off the ground because of budgets and things. So I decided to just start calling myself the sustainability coordinator. I added sustainability coordinator to my email signature, and I even sent some letters to businesses asking for donations of plants from the local nursery, et cetera, and signed
off as the sustainability coordinator. Oh my gosh. I am loving Kelly. I just have to say, Kelly went on to say, the next year, I added it as a suggestion to a list of new roles that were being created, and the school agreed. Kelly, this is the slow play. I know this was like a year in the making. I am intrigued, continue.
They created an official position and gave it to me. It's been a couple of years now, and we now have a team of five teachers and a student club. Kelly. We do heaps of fun things like plant trees, collect batteries, and other recycling and all sorts of things. Thanks for the inspiration, Pam. Wow.
Amazing, right? Amazing. I did just catch up with myself, guys. I think I got a saying wrong. What is it? I said Kelly did the slow play. Is it the long play? The slow play?
You've combined long play and slow burn. Slow game? Slow burn. Slow burn. Long play. Long play. Long play. Slow burn.
你结合了长线布局和慢热。慢热游戏？慢热。慢热。长线布局。长线布局。长线布局。慢热。
You created your own slow play. Slow play. That's very you, Angela. Well, Kelly, I'm impressed with your slow play. Guess what? I liked it so much. It sounded so right to me that I went with it. The slow play.
你创造了属于你自己的慢热。慢热。这很符合你的风格，安吉拉。好吧，凯莉，我对你的慢热印象深刻。你猜怎么着？我太喜欢了。我觉得这听起来太对了，所以我就顺其自然了。慢热。
Thank you. We got another one from Megan H. in Albany, New York. Megan said, this episode inspired me to make up a new job title for myself. What, Megan? I was re-watching the episode, and when Pam says this could work too, I thought, huh, that could work. So I wrote up a very fancy report with a made-up job title, went to my boss, and said, before you came in, the old boss and I were discussing this change.
谢谢。我们收到了来自纽约州奥尔巴尼的梅根·H的另一条留言。梅根说，这一集启发了我为自己编造一个新的职位头衔。什么，梅根？我当时在重看这一集，当潘说这招也行的时候，我想，哈，这倒是个办法。所以我写了一份非常华丽的报告，里面有一个凭空捏造的职位头衔，我去找我的老板说，在你进来之前，老老板和我正在讨论这个变动。
He approved the idea. I got a new title and a $10,000 raise. Oh, my gosh, you know, pretty amazing. Pam, inspiring people to just go for it. Yeah. They're waiting jobs for themselves and getting them approved. I want a new title for my emails. What is Angela's new job title?
他批准了这个想法。我得到了一个新头衔和一万美元的加薪。哦，天哪，你知道的，太惊人了。潘，她激励着人们勇往直前。是的。他们在为自己创造工作并获得批准。我希望我的电子邮件能有一个新头衔。安吉拉的新职位头衔是什么？
Anyone? I'm going to go with ham coordinator. Ham coordinator. I was going to go with boss bitch. Oh, my gosh. This is hard. Not similar. Angela Kinsey.
有人知道吗？我猜是火腿协调员。火腿协调员。我本来想猜女老板。哦，天哪。这很难猜。不太一样。安吉拉·金西。
Boss bitch. I'd like them both at the end of an email. Angela Kinsey, boss bitch hyphen, ham coordinator. I look forward to that email. Okay. On our next business email, I'll just sign off Angela Kinsey, boss bitch. I know. Our company is Ramble.
女老板。我希望在电子邮件的结尾两个都加上。安吉拉·金西，女老板连字符，火腿协调员。我很期待那封邮件。好吧。在我们的下一封商务邮件中，我只需署名安吉拉·金西，女老板。我知道。我们公司是兰布尔。
That's the name of our media company, everybody. Next time someone calls, I'm going to say, you know what? I'm going to go ahead and forward you to our boss bitch, Angela Kinsey. She can address that issue for you. Well let's go back to therapy in the break room. Michael is just continuing to make up a bunch of bologna to Toby. I have to think this went to our standards and practices department when he said, well, the other night I was sitting at the table eating my penis.
那是我们媒体公司的名字，各位。下次有人打电话来，我要说，你知道吗？我要把你的电话转接给我们的女老板，安吉拉·金西。她可以为你解决那个问题。好吧，让我们回到茶水间的心理咨询。迈克尔只是在继续对托比胡编乱造。我不得不认为这通过了我们的标准和实践部门，当他说，嗯，前天我坐在桌子旁吃我的阴茎。
I mean peas. And he's pretty sure he was probed by an alien life force, alph. It might have actually been alph. Yeah. Then he's going to tell Toby that he was raised by wolves. Wolves? I believe he says wolves. And it's interesting, Angela, because it made me go to the script.
我是说豌豆。他非常确信自己被外星生命阿尔夫探测过。那其实可能真的是阿尔夫。是的。然后他要告诉托比他是被狼抚养长大的。狼？我相信他说的是狼。这很有趣，安吉拉，因为这让我想去查剧本。
And first of all, this whole wolf bit, you know, he ends up howling and everything. That was actually from our must shoot candy bag. So that was an ad. And there was extra that went with it where Toby said, don't you mean wolves? And he said, no, Toby, it's not called little red writing hood and the big bad wolf. That was the joke that he was going to say, it's wolves because it's a wolf. Well, that would explain that line. I also was tickled when he said I was 25 years old before I saw my first human being.
首先，整段关于狼的内容，你知道的，他最后又是嚎叫什么的。那其实来自我们的必拍糖果袋。所以那是个即兴发挥。还有额外的内容是托比说，你不觉得你是指狼吗？他说，不，托比，那不叫小红帽和大灰狼。那个笑话是他要说，是狼，因为它是狼。好吧，那就能解释那句台词了。当他说我25岁才第一次见到人类时，我也被逗乐了。
Yeah. That's how long he lived in the forest. Yeah. Toby is finally going to agree with Michael that this is pointless, you know? That's right. And he's going to say, why don't we just run out the clock of your counseling sessions by playing games and he brought some fun stuff that he plays with his daughter. Michael seems happy with this.
是的。他在森林里住了那么久。是的。托比终于要同意迈克尔的观点，认为这毫无意义，你知道吗？没错。他要说，我们为什么不通过玩游戏来耗光你的咨询时间呢，他带了一些他跟女儿一起玩的好玩的东西。迈克尔对此似乎很高兴。
Yes. Meanwhile, Jim has brought Dwight up to front reception and the entire group is going to help transform him into a rich snob. One by one, they're going to like pick apart his wardrobe, his glasses. Do we like them? Do we not? We've stopped on them. Too late.
是的。与此同时，吉姆把德怀特带到了前台，整个小组都要帮他把他改造成一个有钱的势利小人。他们一个接一个地挑剔他的衣着、他的眼镜。我们喜欢吗？还是不喜欢？我们已经踩过它们了。太迟了。
Too late. We've crushed them. Too bad. Kelly says his shirt is disgusto barfo. Mm-hmm. This scene was actually bigger and it showed who contributed to his final outfit. Oh. Yes, in the shooting draft, Andy gives Dwight his vest, Jim gives Dwight his suit jacket,
太迟了。我们把它们压扁了。太糟了。凯莉说他的衬衫恶心透了。嗯哼。这个场景其实更大，并且展示了是谁贡献了他最终的服装。哦。是的，在拍摄剧本中，安迪把他的背心给了德怀特，吉姆把他的西装外套给了德怀特，
Creed gives him an old pipe that he stole from a museum, Kevin gives him a slightly used handkerchief, and they use Phyllis' scarf as an ascot. Wow. Mm-hmm. So I spotted that that was Andy's vest, but I didn't know where the other elements came from. Thank you, Angela. In addition to dressing him differently, they're also going to give him some tips on, I don't
克里德给了他一根从博物馆偷来的旧烟斗，凯文给了他一条稍微用过的手帕，他们用菲利斯的围巾当领结。哇。嗯哼。所以我看出那是安迪的背心，但我不知道其他元素是从哪里来的。谢谢你，安吉拉。除了给他换身打扮，他们还要给他一些关于，我不知道，
know, how to communicate with people. Daryl suggests he say good morning, good afternoon, because people like that, to which Dwight responds, I see you every day. Can I say good month? That is a rain Dwight crossover. Oh, that was 100% rain. Totally rain. Rain would love nothing more than to say good month.
如何与人交流的建议。达里尔建议他说早上好、下午好，因为人们喜欢这样，对此德怀特回答说，我每天都见你。我可以说祝你一个月好吗？那是雷恩·威尔逊的串场风格。哦，那百分之百是雷恩。完全是雷恩。雷恩最喜欢说祝你一个月好。
Yeah. And just get it all done. Yeah, he loves you. He's glad you had a good month. We don't need to rehash everything every day. That's right. So they're done. They're ready to go.
是的。然后把这一切都搞定。是的，他很喜欢你。他很高兴你这一个月过得不错。我们不需要每天都重述所有事情。没错。所以他们完成了。他们准备好了。
Everyone agrees. He looks great. Yeah, go get him, Dwight. Erin's going to take a picture with her disposable camera. And then throw it right in the trash. Yeah. She has a talking head where she says disposable cameras are fun, but it seems wasteful because you never get to see your pictures.
大家都同意。他看起来很棒。去吧，抓住他们，德怀特。艾琳要用她的一次性相机拍张照片。然后把它直接扔进垃圾桶。是的。她有一个访谈镜头，里面说一次性相机很有趣，但似乎很浪费，因为你永远看不到你的照片。
Oh, Erin. We had a fan question from Taylor and Athens, Georgia, who absolutely loves this talking head, this moment with the disposable camera, who wanted to say hats off to the writers, the director, and Ellie, lady, when this episode originally aired, this talking head, it blew up the message boards. Yeah. This was like, it reminds me of something you'd see in the movie, Airplane. Do you know what I mean?
哦，艾琳。我们有一个来自佐治亚州雅典市的粉丝泰勒的提问，他非常喜欢这个访谈镜头，喜欢这个用一次性相机的时刻，他想向编剧、导演和艾莉女士致敬，当这一集最初播出时，这个访谈镜头在留言板上引起了轰动。是的。这就像，让我想起你在电影《空前绝后满天飞》里看到的场景。你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah. Surely you can't be serious. I am serious and don't call me surely. What's your Victor vector? Exactly. It's right in that like comedy lane. And we threw it in there. I think only the character of Erin could get away with this joke.
是的。你肯定不是认真的吧。我是认真的，别叫我雪莉。你的维克托·韦克托是什么？完全正确。它就在那种喜剧赛道上。我们把它加进去了。我想只有艾琳这个角色才能逃过这个笑话的恶搞。
Oh, for sure. Erin or Creed. Yeah. Maybe Creed. You're right. Sidebar note, all the black and white photos in our book, The Office BFFs, were taken with my black and white disposable camera. Oh, yeah.
哦，肯定的。艾琳或克里德。是的。也许是克里德。你说的对。插话说明，我们书《办公室闺蜜》中的所有黑白照片都是用我的黑白一次性相机拍的。哦，是的。
I bought a disposable camera, but just black and white film. I thought it would be so cool and I took all these pictures and then I took it to the kiosk in the mall and got my photos and they're in the book. I'm pretty sure all my photos from the pilot that we put in the book were also a disposable camera. That was like how we did it. I know. It's crazy to think about.
我买了一次性相机，但只有黑白胶卷。我觉得这会很酷，我拍了所有这些照片，然后我把它带到商场的自助冲印亭洗了照片，它们就在书里。我相当确定我们在书里放的来自试播集的所有照片也都是用一次性相机拍的。这就是我们当时的做法。我知道。现在想起来真是太疯狂了。
When we did our book, I found all these pictures as did Jenna and I found like the little disc they would give you. Yeah. They'd put it on a CD-ROM. Yeah. And I found those. They'd go buy a thing to connect it to my computer so I could look at the pictures. Jenna bought the thing and then we kept sharing it back and forth.
当我们写书的时候，我找到了所有这些照片，珍娜也是，我找到了他们会给你的那种小光盘。是的。他们会把它刻录在光盘上。是的。我找到了那些。他们去买了一个可以把它连接到我电脑上的东西，这样我就可以看照片了。珍娜买了那个东西，然后我们一直借来借去。
She'd drop it off to me. I'd bring it to her and then eventually my husband was like, should I just buy you? It's $12.99, ladies. I think you can have each have one. I finally got one. Well, for those of you keeping track of the Dwayangela romance, Angela snags Dwight right before he leaves and says, hey, my place tonight, wear this, don't forget your pipe. Yeah.
她把它放在我这。我把它带给她，然后最后我丈夫说，我是不是应该直接给你买一个？女士们，只要12.99美元。我想你们每人都可以有一个。我终于买了一个。好吧，对于那些关注德怀特和安吉拉恋情的人来说，安吉拉在德怀特离开前一把抓住他说，嘿，今晚来我这，穿这个，别忘了你的烟斗。是的。
She's liking this whole new look. And then she gets out her procreation punch card. Yeah. Dwight's like, do you have your card? Yeah. So baby making on the way here. What punches this? Is this punch two?
她很喜欢这个全新的造型。然后她拿出了她的生育打孔卡。是的。德怀特就像是，你带卡了吗？是的。所以在去那里的路上就能造小孩了。这个打的是什么孔？这是打第二个孔吗？
She used one punch for down in the warehouse. I think this is punch two. And then well, next week in Andy's play, you'll see what happens. Oh boy. Did you punch three? No. Oh. Save it for next week, lady.
她为了在仓库下面造人打了一个孔。我想这是第二个孔。然后，好吧，下周在安迪的戏剧里，你就会看到会发生什么。哦，天哪。你打第三个孔了吗？没有。哦。留到下周吧，女士。
You've already watched it. I haven't watched it because of my summer cold behind. It's a fun one. Well back in the break room, Toby and Michael are playing Connect 4. What did it cost us to use Connect 4? Do we have dates? Oh, well, Randy didn't tell me the cost, but he said they gave us permission to use the game provided we didn't throw the game at Toby or show it being knocked off the table.
你已经看过了。我没看是因为我得了夏季感冒。这集挺有趣的。好吧，回到茶水间，托比和迈克尔正在玩四子棋。我们用四子棋花了多少钱？我们有日期吗？哦，好吧，兰迪没有告诉我费用，但他说他们允许我们使用这个游戏，前提是我们不能把游戏砸向托比，或者表现得把它从桌子上撞下来。
Okay. But then it was fine. All right. So yes. Well, Connect 4 is working. Michael is sharing. Toby is like, oh my gosh, it's happening. Yeah.
好吧。但后来一切都好。好吧。所以是的。嗯，四子棋管用了。迈克尔在分享。托比就像是，哦，天哪，有进展了。是的。
He's sharing all about Jeff. This breakthrough moment where Michael says that his stepdad, Jeff, respected the manager. Yeah. Michael's the manager. Michael's the manager. Still trying to get Jeff's favor. We got mail lady from Vicky S in Gulfport, Mississippi, who said, I have been a children's therapist since 1995.
他分享了所有关于杰夫的事。这个突破性的时刻是迈克尔说他的继父杰夫尊重经理。是的。迈克尔是经理。迈克尔是经理。仍然试图赢得杰夫的青睐。我们收到了来自密西西比州格尔夫波特的维琪·S的信，她写道，我自1995年以来一直是一名儿童治疗师。
And I think Toby did an excellent job utilizing games as a tool to get Michael to talk. Great job writers. And Laura L from Kansas City, Missouri said, I'm a social worker and sometimes therapist. And this episode has been used in trainings. This episode? Yes. To demonstrate the therapeutic power of play, Toby knows his skills. I would have never imagined that this episode is a training video.
我认为托比在利用游戏作为工具让迈克尔开口说话方面做得非常出色。编剧们干得好。来自密苏里州堪萨斯城的劳拉·L说，我是一名社会工作者，有时也是治疗师。这一集曾被用在培训中。这一集？是的。为了展示游戏的治疗力量，托比深谙他的技能。我绝不会想到这一集竟然是一个培训视频。
They move on from Connect 4 to playing cards. And Michael's going to share a story about his dog running away and how he wouldn't go back to the park where the dog ran away because he was afraid he would see his dog there with someone else. Yes. He was running with another kid and Toby says, it's very important for you to be liked, isn't it? And Michael's like, oh no.
他们从四子棋转到了玩纸牌。迈克尔要分享一个关于他的狗跑掉的故事，以及他为什么不愿意回到狗跑掉的公园，因为他害怕在那里看到他的狗和别人在一起。是的。他跟另一个孩子一起跑了，托比说，被别人喜欢对你来说非常重要，不是吗？迈克尔就像是，哦，不。
He escalates so quickly, like he just goes off, he's so mad that Toby got him to be vulnerable. Yeah. He gives him the finger and he walks out. Yeah. Guess what? Standards and practices. Step it in. We had to blur the double bird.
他的情绪升级得太快了，就像他直接爆发了一样，他太生气了，因为托比竟然让他敞开心扉变得脆弱。是的。他竖起中指然后走了出去。是的。你猜怎么着？标准和实践部门。介入了。我们不得不给双中指打上马赛克。
Here were their exact words. It's my new favorite thing. Is this from Randy? Yep. Quote, please blur Michael's hands as he flips the bird in parentheses, you, to Toby during the counseling session. I like how they had to spill it out. In case we thought it was another bird, maybe there's a random bird.
以下是他们的原话。这是我的新最爱。这是兰迪说的吗？是的。引述，请在括号中注明（你），在咨询期间迈克尔向托比竖中指时，请将迈克尔的手打上马赛克。我喜欢他们必须把这个拼出来的方式。以防我们以为那是另一只鸟，也许有一只随机的鸟。
No. No, it's the FU bird. And lady, I have one more piece of mail from Stephanie Ellen St. Louis talking about Toby's therapy. Stephanie said, I am a therapist and while the inconsistencies with professional ethics don't bug me, I do need to point them out in this episode. Number one, Toby would need to be licensed in Pennsylvania, which would typically require him to actively be practicing over the years.
不。不，那是竖中指的鸟。女士，我还有一封来自圣路易斯的斯蒂芬妮·艾伦的信，谈到了托比的治疗。斯蒂芬妮说，我是一名治疗师，虽然专业道德方面的不一致并没有困扰我，但我确实需要指出这一集中的这些问题。第一，托比需要在宾夕法尼亚州获得执照，这通常需要他在这些年里积极执业。
It's not enough just to have a diploma. Okay. Okay. Number two, there is a major conflict of interest in having Toby be Michael's counselor because you're not allowed to have a dual relationship with a client. So ethically, he should have referred Michael to someone else, although Stephanie points out that would not be nearly as funny. True, Stephanie.
仅仅有一个文凭是不够的。好的。好的。第二，让托比担任迈克尔的顾问存在重大的利益冲突，因为你不被允许与客户建立双重关系。所以在道德上，他应该把迈克尔推荐给别人，尽管斯蒂芬妮指出那将远没有那么搞笑。真的，斯蒂芬妮。
Yes. True. Number three, I work with kids and teens doing trauma therapy at a children's advocacy center. And the game strategy that Toby uses is something I do all the time when there's a kid who doesn't want to be at counseling. Uno is literally a lifesaver. Aw. So that's the part that we got right.
是的。真的。第三，我和儿童和青少年一起工作，在儿童倡导中心做创伤治疗。托比使用的游戏策略是我经常做的事情，当有一个孩子不想去接受咨询时。UNO牌简直是救星。啊。所以这是我们做对的部分。
Well, Pam is going to start putting her plan in motion. She goes up to Gabe. This made me sweat. The scene made me sweat. I was like, oh my God, Pam, oh my God. She goes, you know what? I haven't been paid yet. I'm not blaming you.
好吧，潘要开始付诸她的计划了。她走向盖布。这让我出了汗。这个场景让我出了汗。我当时想，哦，天哪，潘，哦，天哪。她说，你知道吗？我还没拿到工资。我不是在怪你。
I'm not blaming anyone. I'm sure it just got lost in the paperwork. Gabe is so relieved that Pam isn't upset with him. And he's like, you know what? So you get the department head signatures so we can really get the ball rolling here. Yes. And Pam explains that this office has a lot of one-person departments. So there are a lot of department heads.
我不是在怪任何人。我确信它只是在文件里弄丢了。盖布非常庆幸潘没有生他的气。他说，你知道吗？那你去拿部门主管的签字，这样我们才能真正让事情进展顺利。是的。潘解释说，这个办公室有很多一人部门。所以有很多部门主管。
Which I didn't realize. I didn't realize Meredith was the head of a department. Yeah. Isn't she the head of like quality control or something? Isn't it just her and Creed? I don't know. I wasn't sure. But first she goes in and gets Michael's signature.
我以前没意识到这一点。我没意识到梅雷迪思是一个部门的主管。是的。她难道不是质量控制部门的负责人什么的吗？难道不是只有她和克里德吗？我不知道。我不太确定。但首先她进去拿了迈克尔的签字。
He is still upset about his counseling. He doesn't look at the form. He doesn't ask her any questions. Then she's going to go over to Meredith. What are you doing in this scene? It looks like you're, I don't know what you're doing, a dance move, you're kind of, what is this? Yes.
他还在为他的咨询生气。他没有看表格。他没有问她任何问题。然后她要去梅雷迪思那里。你在这一幕里在做什么？看起来你，我不知道你在做什么，一个舞蹈动作，你有点，这到底是什么？是的。
We got questions about this. Abby S. from Atlanta, Georgia would also like to know what the hell is Pam saying or doing with Meredith? Larissa W. from Littleton, Colorado says, did I have scripted lines or was I improvising? Because it's, you know, voiceover with a talking head. Here's what it said in the script. B-roll. Pam makes Ribbled Humping Gesture by Meredith's Desk.
我们收到了关于这个的问题。来自佐治亚州亚特兰大的艾比·S也想知道潘到底在对梅雷迪思说些什么或者做些什么。来自科罗拉多州利特尔顿的劳里萨·W说，我是有剧本台词还是在即兴发挥？因为这是，你知道的，带有访谈镜头的旁白。剧本里是这样写的。B卷。潘在梅雷迪思的办公桌旁做出下流的耸动动作。
I thought it was a humping gesture, but I didn't want to throw that out there in case this was some dance move. I didn't know. Well, first of all, when I read the stage direction, I had to look up the definition of Ribbled, and it means referring to a sexual matter in an amusingly coarse or irreverent way. A synonym is body, and I'll have you know, standards and practices. When they read the script, they had something to say about this gesture.
我以为那是一个耸动动作，但我不想把它说出来，以防这只是某种舞蹈动作。我不知道。好吧，首先，当我读到舞台指示时，我不得不查阅下流一词的定义，它的意思是：以一种有趣而粗俗或不敬的方式提及性方面的事。一个同义词是粗俗，我得告诉你，标准和实践部门。当他们阅读剧本时，他们对这个动作有话要说。
Please tell me what they said. They said, quote, please use your discretion staging the scene where Pam makes a gesture. She, quote, Ribbled Humping Gesture. It should play as funny, not explicit. Man, Pam is working it. She knows what's going to work with each person. She really does. It says at Angela's desk, Pam points to various cat pictures and rearranges them more nicely
请告诉我说什么了。他们说，引述，请在潘做出动作的场景中酌情处理。她，引述，下流的耸动动作。它应该表现得搞笑，而不是露骨。天哪，潘太有一套了。她知道对每个人该用什么方法。她真的很会。剧本上说在安吉拉的办公桌旁，潘指着各种猫的照片，把它们在桌子上重新整理得更好看，
on her desk, lighting Angela up, who signs as she talks. Then Pam is going to go into Daryl's office, and he's very interested in her new position because he might like to have corkboard all over his office because it's something that he saw that Kate Walsh has done to her home office he saw it on TV. This got me so tickled. You guys know Kate Walsh is one of my good, good pals. We go way back to our improv days. Jenna, you know you even did improv with us one time.
让安吉拉容光焕发，她一边说话一边签字。然后潘要走进达里尔的办公室，他对她的新职位很感兴趣，因为他也想在办公室里贴满软木板，因为这是他在电视上看到凯特·沃尔什对她的家庭办公室做过的事情。这把我逗乐了。你们知道凯特·沃尔什是我的好闺蜜之一。我们得追溯到我们的即兴表演时期。珍娜，你知道你甚至有一次跟我们一起做过即兴表演吗？
Oh yeah, that's right. Yeah. Oh my God. We drug you into one of our improv shows, but you guys might also know her as Addison from Grey's Anatomy plus a gazillion other things she's done. So when I saw Daryl mention her, I was like, oh my God. So I called Kate and I said, Kate, did you know you're mentioned in this office episode by Daryl?
哦，是的，没错。是的。哦，天哪。我们把你拉进了我们的一个即兴表演秀里，但你们可能也知道她是《实习医生格蕾》里的艾迪生，此外她还演过成百上千的其他东西。所以当我看到达里尔提到她时，我心想，哦，天哪。所以我打电话给凯特说，凯特，你知道你在办公室这一集里被达里尔提到了吗？
And she was like, no, I had no idea. And I said, yeah, I mean, Daryl in the episode says he saw your home office and it's covered in corkboard. What do you have to say about that? And here's what she had to say. Hi. This is Kate Walsh. I have never had a home office covered in corkboard, but now I'm wondering why I haven't.
她说，不，我完全不知道。我说，是的，我是说达里尔在这一集里说他看到你的家庭办公室了，而且贴满了软木板。你对此有什么想说的吗？以下是她的发言。嗨。我是凯特·沃尔什。我从来没有过一个贴满软木板的家庭办公室，但现在我在想我为什么没有。
That sounds delightful. I do love a pinboard. I love her so much. Thanks, Kate. Well, I spotted something in Daryl's office. It's not corkboard, but it's 16 minutes and 53 seconds. There's a blue football helmet with a white paw print hanging on his like coat rack thing. Yeah, I saw it too.
听起来很棒。我确实很喜欢钉板。我太喜欢她了。谢谢，凯特。好吧，我在达里尔的办公室里发现了一些东西。不是软木板，但在16分53秒处。他的衣帽架上挂着一个带白色爪印的蓝色美式足球头盔。是的，我也看到了。
It's the Valley View High School Cougar's football helmet. And I just thought that was an amazing detail. And that's where Pam went to high school. And I guess Daryl did too and played football. With Roy, probably. Maybe so. Well, full Pam might be in trouble. Oh, no.
那是山景高中美洲狮队的橄榄球头盔。我只是觉得这是一个了不起的细节。那是潘的高中。我猜达里尔也是，而且还打过橄榄球。可能跟罗伊一起。也许吧。好吧，完全模式全开的潘可能有麻烦了。哦，不。
Because Gabe said he's gone through three years worth of information and can't find anything about Pam being the office administrator. He says he doesn't want to accuse her of anything. So maybe she could just admit, Pam's like, admit what? Pam realizes that Gabe is so afraid of confrontation that he will not accuse her of being a liar or making it up. He won't do it. He won't do it.
因为盖布说他翻阅了三年的资料，却找不到任何关于潘是办公室管理员的信息。他说他不想指责她什么。所以也许她可以承认，潘就像是，承认什么？潘意识到盖布太害怕对峙了，以至于他不敢指责她是个骗子或凭空捏造。他做不到。他做不到。
And then he folds and Pam says, let me know if you need a new chair or anything that an office administrator can handle. And Gabe says, can I get one of those name plates that says Gabe Lewis? Pam says, sure. Anything else? He says, nope. And that's it. She's got it.
然后他妥协了，潘说，如果你需要新椅子或者任何办公室管理员能处理的事情，随时告诉我。盖布说，我能要一个写着盖布·刘易斯的这种名牌吗？潘说，当然。还要别的吗？他说，没了。就这样。她搞定了。
Office administrator. It's done. Pam has a talking head where she says the first lesson of watching World Poker Tour at 2 AM, you play the opponent, not the cards. Lady, we got a fan question from Natalie F. in San Antonio, Texas, who would like to know, what do you guys think about the way Pam gets her promotion? The first time I watched it, I was excited for her, but in rewatching it, I was kind of bothered by her dishonesty.
办公室管理员。成了。潘有一个访谈镜头，她说凌晨两点看世界扑克巡回赛的第一课，你玩的是对手，而不是手里的牌。女士，我们收到了来自德克萨斯州圣安东尼奥的娜塔莉·F的一个粉丝提问，她想知道，你们怎么看潘获得晋升的方式？我第一次看的时候，我为她感到兴奋，但在重看时，她的不诚实让我有点困扰。
What do we think? I mean, Natalie, it's a little layered, right? Because I'm so happy Pam finally was an advocate for herself and made something happen. Natalie, I lied all the time when I was an up and coming actress. If I had an audition, I lied and said I had a dental appointment. It was just easier. To get out of work. Well, you guys know how I got my internship on Conan O'Brien.
我们怎么看？我的意思是，娜塔莉，这有点多层含义，对吧？因为我太高兴潘终于为自己发声并促成了一些事情。娜塔莉，当我是一个崭露头角的演员时，我一直在撒谎。如果我有试镜，我就会撒谎说我有牙科预约。这样比较容易。为了请假不工作。好吧，你们知道我是怎么在柯南·奥布莱恩节目获得实习机会的吗？
That's what I was going to say. You shared that. You totally just lied your way into it. I just kept calling and saying, yeah, I just booked someone. They said I'm hired. I know. I guess it begs the question like, when is it unethical and when is it ambition? When is it to be admired and when is it to be faulted?
我正要这么说。你分享过那个。你完全是靠撒谎混进去的。我只是不断打电话说，是的，我刚刚安排了一个人。他们说我被雇用了。我知道。我想这引发了一个问题，比如，什么时候是不道德的，什么时候是野心？什么时候该被钦佩，什么时候该受责备？
Yeah. I think it's layered, Natalie. I'm happy for her in this moment. I bet Mike Scher's book, How to Be Perfect, would tell us the moral answer to this question. Perhaps we should ask him. Did Pam getting this position benefit everyone else in the office? Were their lives made better? So is lying okay if you make other people's lives better?
是的。我觉得这很复杂，娜塔莉。我为她在这个时刻感到高兴。我敢打赌迈克尔·舒尔的书《如何完美》会告诉我们这个问题的道德答案。也许我们应该问问他。潘获得这个职位是否让办公室里的其他人受益了？他们的生活变得更好了吗？所以，如果你让别人的生活变得更好，撒谎是可以接受的吗？
See that's complicated. It's very complicated and also people were really liking this moment at first of Pam, but as we get into some of the things she's going to do as office administrator, people turned on her. We'll discuss it. And when I say people, I mean fans turned on the storyline because Pam starts kind of using her power in ways that maybe people didn't care for it. Natalie, great question.
看，这很复杂。这非常复杂，而且人们一开始真的很喜欢潘的这个时刻，但随着我们进入她作为办公室管理员将要做的一些事情，人们开始背叛她。我们会讨论这个的。当我说人们时，我是说粉丝们开始反对这个故事情节，因为潘开始以某种方式滥用她的权力，也许人们并不喜欢这样。娜塔莉，好问题。
Lady, let's go to the mall because Jim and Andy have brought Dwight to precious heirlooms to confront the salesperson. To get his revenge. But the salesperson recognizes Dwight. He's like, oh, I remember you. Yes, you were here yesterday. We took a picture. We were worried.
女士，让我们去商场吧，因为吉姆和安迪把德怀特带到了珍贵传家宝店去找销售员对质。去报复。但销售员认出了德怀特。他就像，哦，我记得你。是的，你昨天来过。我们拍了照。我们很担心。
You had blood stains on your hands and you were wearing overalls. And Jim is like, wow, blah, blah, and yes, there we see why they denied Dwight entry. He has his hands. They're all red. They're on the glass of precious heirlooms. But Dwight is still going to try to have his pretty woman moment. He is. He still wants to go pretty woman on their ass.
你手上带着血迹，还穿着工装裤。吉姆就像是，哇，啦啦啦，是的，这就是为什么他们拒绝德怀特入内。他的手。全都是红的。它们贴在珍贵传家宝店的玻璃上。但德怀特仍然要试图重现他的《风月俏佳人》时刻。他是的。他仍然想对他们这帮人上演一出《风月俏佳人》。
And I have the question for you. I'm titling this. Who did it best? Julia? Hi. Hello. Do you remember me? No.
我有个问题要问你们。我给这个起个标题。谁演得最好？朱莉娅？嗨。你好。你还记得我吗？不。
I'm sorry. I was in here yesterday. You wouldn't wait on me? Oh. You work on commission, right? Yes. Big mistake. Big.
我很抱歉。我昨天来过这里。你不肯接待我？哦。你拿提成对吧？是的。大错特错。大错。
Huge. I have to go shopping now. Or Dwight. When I came to your finest hat, you are, I'm going to, okay, listen, you can't treat. Thank you. Good morning, sir. Okay. Let's go.
特大。我现在得去买东西了。或者德怀特。当我来到你最好的帽子店，你是，我要，好吧，听着，你不能这样对待。谢谢。早上好，先生。好的。我们走吧。
You made a big mistake. Huge. There it is. I mean, Dwight just keeps, he's like this robot that's malfunctioning. He's like, good morning, good day, sir. Hello. Top of the morning. What?
你犯了大错。特大错。就是这样。我的意思是，德怀特一直在，他就像个故障的机器人。他就像是，早上好，日安，先生。你好。早上好。什么？
How dare you? Yes. Another guest star alert, Eric Zuckerman played the salesperson, and I've got an interesting bit of trivia on Eric because he falls into my other favorite category that I mentioned. He has not only played two different characters in two different episodes of Law and Order. He's also done it on Law and Order criminal intent. Multiple characters across the franchise. Yes.
你怎么敢？是的。又一个客串明星警报，埃里克·祖克曼饰演销售员，关于埃里克我有一个有趣的冷知识，因为他落入了提到的我另一个最喜欢的类别。他不仅在两集不同的《法律与秩序》中饰演了两个不同的角色。他还在《法律与秩序：洛杉矶》中这样做过。在整个系列中饰演多个角色。是的。
He's also had recurring roles on Revenge and Orange is the New Black. I also have a bag breakdown, Dwight's bags. Yeah. All of his shopping bags. One of them is a Steamtown Mall bag and the other is from a store called La Tida. Have we featured La Tida before? I'm not sure, but they're a real store in the Steamtown Mall. They were there from the day it opened until it closed in 2019.
他还在《复仇》和《女子监狱》中扮演过常驻角色。我还有一个购物袋解析，德怀特买的袋子。是的。他所有的购物袋。其中一个是蒸汽镇商场的袋子，另一个来自一家名为La Tida的商店。我们之前介绍过La Tida吗？我不确定，但它们是蒸汽镇商场里的一家真实商店。它们从商场开业一直开到2019年关门。
What did La Tida sell? They sold like fancy trinkets and nice items for your house for giving gifts. Dwight is on a fancy shopping spree. He certainly is. If he's shopping at La Tida, that should tell precious heirlooms something. Before he leaves, he's going to go ahead and buy the wizard. Yeah. And Jim is like, Dwight, I know, but he buys the wizard.
La Tida卖什么？他们卖一些精美的小饰品和送礼用的优质家居用品。德怀特正在进行一次高级购物狂欢。他确实在这么做。如果他在La Tida购物，那应该能说明珍贵传家宝店的问题了。在他离开之前，他要顺便把那个巫师买下来。是的。吉姆就像是，德怀特，我知道，但他买下了巫师。
This scene would have continued, Jenna. They would have left the store and as they're leaving, Dwight smashes the wizard statue and Jim and Andy are like, what are you doing? And he prized the crystal out of the wizard's hand and he's like, you think I was here for this wizard? It's the crystal. Why do I remember that scene? I wasn't there when they shot it.
这个场景本该继续下去的，珍娜。他们本该离开商店，正当他们离开时，德怀特砸碎了巫师雕像，吉姆和安迪就像，你在干什么？他从巫师的手里撬出水晶，他说，你以为我是为了这个巫师来的吗？是这个水晶。为什么我记得那个场景？他们拍的时候我不在现场。
Is it just like one of those moments when something was so funny to me at a table read that I've never forgotten it? Yeah. Because I remember that. Dwight had it out for the wizard and stole his crystal. I wish we would have kept that in. It's in the deleted scenes on the DVD. It's really funny.
这就像是那种在剧本朗读会上对我来说太好笑了以至于我永远不会忘记的时刻吗？是的。因为我记得那个。德怀特跟那个巫师杠上了，还偷了他的水晶。我真希望我们把那个保留下来。它在DVD的被删减片段里。真的很搞笑。
I guess we should talk about what happened between Michael and Toby after their session ended so abruptly with the double bird. Yeah. Toby just gives Michael the forums and is like, you fill him out, say you completed the counseling, turn him in. I don't care. He's done with it. I guess Michael accidentally checked off severe.
我想我们应该谈谈在他们的咨询以竖中指戛然而止之后，迈克尔和托比之间发生了什么。是的。托比直接把表格给迈克尔，就像是，你自己填，说你完成了咨询，交上去。我不在乎。他受够了。我猜迈克尔不小心勾选了严重。
He didn't read the forums. Yeah. He said that he was severe in all categories and Gabe is like, wow, is this really how you feel about Michael after your counseling? And Toby's like, yeah, guess what? This is going to lead to more counseling. Yeah. Michael is so mad.
他没看表格。是的。他说他在所有类别中都很严重，盖布就像是，哇，咨询过后你对迈克尔真的是这种感觉吗？托比就像是，对，你猜怎么着？这会导致更多的咨询。是的。迈克尔气坏了。
But Toby has an idea. He says, you know what? Just forget it. Just get out your notebook. We'll just do some drawings. We'll just kill the time. Oh, I want you to know, I wish I had kept this prop. Me too.
但托比有个主意。他说，你知道吗？算了吧。拿出你的笔记本。我们画画图。我们来消磨时间。哦，我想让你知道，我真希望我留下了这个道具。我也是。
I wish I had it in a frame. Michael draws Dwight and Angela. Angela's taller than Dwight in the drawing. I wish I had this picture. I can't believe Toby is still trying to counsel Michael. He's like, wow, Angela is taller than Dwight. I wonder why you drew it that way. Yeah.
我真希望把它裱起来。迈克尔画了德怀特和安吉拉。在画里安吉拉比德怀特高。我真希望我有这张画。我真不敢相信托比还在试图辅导迈克尔。他就像是，哇，安吉拉比德怀特高。我在想你为什么要那样画。是的。
Is that how it seems to you? Like, Toby. Toby, stop. Oh, my goodness. But the whole episode ends with a Ryan talking head. Yes, it does. It's one of the talking heads that would have been this runner of everyone in the bullpen commenting on Michael's counseling.
在你看来是这样的吗？就像是，托比。托比，停下。哦，天哪。但整集的结尾是一个瑞恩的访谈镜头。是的，确实如此。这是那些访谈镜头之一，原本会成为 bullpen 里所有人对迈克尔咨询发表评论的一个长桥段。
But here's the thing. Is it a talking head or is it a series of talking heads? We had a fan question from Joshua P. and Cincinnati and many others who would like to know when Ryan lists off all of these various thoughts on therapy and then at the end says I don't know, just use the best one, were those scripted or were they candy bag alts and then they just stitched them together as one joke? I really appreciate this fan question, Angela, because remember in Niagara, they had a bunch of candy bag alts for Dwight about his, like, meat business?
但问题是。这是一个访谈镜头还是一系列访谈镜头？我们收到了来自辛辛那提的约书亚·P和许多其他人的粉丝提问，他们想知道当瑞恩列出所有这些关于治疗的各种想法，最后说我不知道，挑个最好的用吧，这些是有剧本的还是糖果袋即兴发挥，然后他们把它们拼凑成了一个笑话？我真的很感激这个粉丝提问，安吉拉，因为还记得在尼亚加拉那集里，他们为德怀特关于他的肉类生意的谈话准备了一堆糖果袋即兴台词吗？
Yes, and they made them all one. Yes. By accident. Yes. They didn't catch it until editing. So, what happened here? I want you to know I went to the shooting draft and this is one complete talking head. It's not a bunch of candy bag alts, it's one talking head, BJ read it as scripted and the
是的，他们把它们做成了一个。是的。不小心弄的。是的。他们直到剪辑才发现。所以，这里发生了什么？我想让你知道我去了拍摄剧本那里，这是一个完整的访谈镜头。这不是一堆糖果袋即兴发挥，这是一个访谈镜头，BJ照着剧本读的，
last line of this talking head is, I don't know, just use the best one. Because Ryan is now savvy with the camera crew, right? He is. He knows they're going to edit. He's, you know, he's going through his suspenders and orange watch phase and his glasses and his fedora hat. He's savvy now. He is.
这个访谈镜头的最后一句台词是，我不知道，挑个最好的用吧。因为瑞恩现在对摄像机组很精明了，对吧？他是的。他知道他们会剪辑。他，你知道的，他正在经历他的背带、橙色手表阶段，戴着眼镜和呢帽。他现在很精明了。他是的。
I mean, listen, when we did the lip dub, he knew I'm going to use this as an opportunity to advertise. That's right, for Wolf. Mm-hmm. Well, you guys, that was counseling. I so enjoyed rewatching this. Big thank yous to Randy Cordray, Elise Myers, who you can find at Elise, E-L-Y-S-E, underscore M-Y-E-R-S on Instagram.
我是说，听着，当我们做假唱视频时，我知道我要利用这个机会做广告。没错，为了沃尔夫。嗯哼。好吧，各位，那是咨询。我很享受重看这一集。非常感谢兰迪·科德雷、伊莉斯·迈尔斯，你可以在Instagram上通过Elise，E-L-Y-S-E，下划线M-Y-E-R-S找到她。
My friend Kate Walsh, who is going to be starring in a new Greg Garcia show called Sprung. Kate is just amazing. She's just in everything. She's already on Emily in Paris. I know. You can find her on Instagram, at Kate, K-A-T-E, W-A-L-S-H, and my dear friend Mica, who picked up the phone. Thank you, Michael.
我的朋友凯特·沃尔什，她将主演一部由格雷格·加西亚创作的新剧叫《弹跳》。凯特真是太棒了。她无处不在。她已经出演了《艾米丽在巴黎》。我知道。你可以在Instagram上找到她，账号是@Kate，K-A-T-E，W-A-L-S-H，还有接电话的好朋友迈卡。谢谢你，迈克尔。
Thank you. You can find him on Instagram, at Ultra Mike, U-L-T-R-A-M-I-K-E. I am really liking season seven. Let me just say that. Me too. These are good episodes. You guys, I jumped ahead the other day and I watched Andy's play and sex education. We've got lots to cover, lady.
谢谢。你可以在Instagram上找到他，账号是@UltraMike，U-L-T-R-A-M-I-K-E。我真的很喜欢第七季。我就这么说吧。我也是。这些都是好剧集。你们知道，我前几天跳着看了安迪的戏剧和性教育。我们有很多内容要讲，女士。
I can't wait. See you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Ear Wolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe.
我等不及了。下周见。回头见。感谢收听 Office Ladies。《Office Ladies》由 Ear Wolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制作。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉特创作的《橡胶树》。有关《Office Ladies》的无广告版本，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。在 Stitcher Premium 上享受一个月的免费试用，请使用代码 Office。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。